[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je sais que david de voies côté pas
forcément une histoire des cigares
c'est l'histoire de deux mecs qui se
pose une question personnelle et cette
question personnelle est en train de
devenir petit à petit de questions de
société c'est le lien entre
l'alimentation et la sécurité
et ce gamin c'est moi je suis né en 1975
à toulouse à trois ans après le rapport
du club de rome établi par le couple
meadows qui montrait pour la première
fois les limites planétaires et le fait
qu' il est temps d une planète finie on
ne peut pas continuer à penser
l'économie qui s'affranchit justement
des limites physiques
alors évidemment je n'avais pas tout cet
état mais dans les années soixante dix
il y avait des séries télévisées des
dessins animés qui était inspiré
justement de ce rapport milloz du club
de rome s'était il était une fois
l'homme d'albert barillet et albator
albator c'était une série éminemment
politique alors mes grands parents
étaient agriculteurs
sur le post les causses du quercy dans
le lot sur une ferme et diversifiée il y
avait des brebis des productions
avicoles à des légumes des céréales a et
je veux voyez que c'était une ferme
autonome qui suffisait gras demain à
l'alimentation de la famille voire au
delà
et petit à petit j'ai vu cette cette
ferme l'oustal abandonné les cultures
nourricières à pour arriver maintenant
maintenant la mort de mes grands parents
à une maison qui ne produit que de la
menthe et du thym mais depuis petit
juste au niveau du jardin mais depuis
petit je m'agite toujours bien donc à la
ferme était productrice d'alimentation
je mange très bien
l'état après je mangeais toujours bien
et maintenant qu'il n'y a que du persil
et du tangue je mange toujours bien et
je me posais des questions and is an
voilà est-ce que comment ça se passe
comment ça peut tenir
donc en fait j'ai choisi de faire des
études de géographie aménagement du
territoire et mon premier travail ça a
était d'être conseiller en développement
local dans une collectivité locale
après avoir installé les peas et à cette
même époque le 1er janvier 2000
c'était ma décision du millénaire je me
suis engagé je suis les sapeurs pompiers
donc j'ai embrassé le monde de la
sécurité civile sapeurs pompiers
volontaires et en 2003 j'apprends
l'existence de systèmes pas connu tout
le système des amap
ce sont des consommateurs qui passent un
contrat avec des producteurs et ce sont
les trois piliers de l'expression
devenue désuète du développement durable
mais ça permet quand même de poser
certaines choses le volet économie
écologie et social économie les
producteurs vendent leur production au
prix minimum que ça leur coûte la
dépense du consommateur reste fixé sur
le territoire
donc en fait d'y vivre de leur métier
leveaux l'écologie c'est le consommateur
passe on comptera en lui disant ok je
t'achète à condition que ce soit bio ou
que ça le devienne
donc en fait il un accompagnement vers
des productions plus respectueuse de
l'environnement et le volet social c'est
à dire que vorm maintenant que je vis de
mon métier moi le producteur je peux
rester sur le territoire et ma famille
faire à travailler les services autour
et tout ça et des liens entre
consommateurs également et entre
consommateurs et producteurs et à cette
époque là je voyais une quatrième pilier
un pilier que je que je n'osais pas
forcément avancer c'était le pilier de
la sécurité pourquoi la sécurité mais
tout simplement parce que
80 m pour ça va à peu près de notre
nourriture est acheté en grande surface
même un milieu rural nous ne produisons
plus notre nourriture à titre individuel
nous ne la stockons plus nos
infrastructures nourricière c'est à dire
les paysans à force de ne plus les faire
à travailler ils ont disparu comme des
muscles qu'on entretient plus il n'y a
pas de stock dans les collectivités
locales les gradins de surface donc que
même pas deux ou trois jours de stocks
sans panique et il n'y a pas de stocks
alimentaires la stratégie que des tas
d'objets m'étais dit ben était ce
système des amap à miniature c'est
quelque part ce qu'il faudrait arriver à
faire au niveau plus large au niveau de
la restauration collective au niveau des
de restauration d'entreprise les
cantines tout ça est la cause soit sur
le reste de la consommation c'est à dire
créer des périmètres de sécurité
alimentaire partout et ça ça m'est resté
donc on a monté les premières amap du
département de l'aude en 2004 à l'époque
où il y en avait très peu en france
avait découpé et on est arrivé à avoir
des listes d'attentes énorme et on ne
trouvait pas de producteur à mettre en
face et en fait je m'étais dit mais
c'est quelque part le contraire de notre
de ce que l'on observe dans notre
système économique d'habitude il y à une
concurrence entre producteurs entre
entreprises mais là il avait une
concurrence entre consommateurs qui
était pourtant organisé et solvable et
là je me dis quand même et donc du coup
notre producteur il a abandonné ses
groupes de consommateurs de toulouse
pour venir nous fournir nous a cassé le
dari ces pauvres toulousaine république
et donc je m'étais dit quand même ces
pauvres toulouse elle a maintenant
qu'ils ont ils avaient en effet de
trouver des producteurs pour les
alimenter et maintenant c'est le rural
qui commence à manger bon et là je
voyais que dans mon département de
l'aude le
l'expression circuits courts étaient
était combattu par système économique et
productiviste dominant le conseil
général était comptera également donc je
m'étais dit quand même j'ai démontré un
petit comme pouvait y arriver qu'il y
avait un débouché que c'était bon pour
la sécurité mais eux ils veulent pas
donc qu'est ce que j'ai fait et bennane
ans je me suis mis en scène et j'ai je
me suis lancée pendant un an dans un
défi personnel de ne consommer que des
produits locaux issus d'un rayon de 150
km autour de castelnaudary donc pas non
plus de café plus de chocolat plus de
bananes tout ça est en fait c'était
justement pour alerter sur notre degré
de vulnérabilité par rapport aux
approvisionnements
sachant que nos arts urbains n'ont que 2
% d'autonomie alimentaire même en milieu
rural mais a même tu as montré des
pistes des pistes d'action et de
solutions donc ça a été extrêmement
médiatisé le mot locavore est rentré
dans le dictionnaire cependant qu'il est
monté mais c'est mon expérience qui l'a
popularisé je m'étais fait suivre par
une conseillère en économie sociale et
familiale et qui a démontré que ça ne
coûtait pas plus cher de manger local
quand on cuisine quand on est des
produits frais de saison c'est toujours
moins cher je ne suis pas tombé malade à
paname avait dit tu vas tu anémiée tu
auras plus de vitamines tout ça mais les
gens y passent
obnubilés par par le marketing il pense
que les vitamines ne se retrouve que
dans les bouteilles de jus qui se
survitaminé mais après destruction des
vitamines naturelles
bon c'est pas que d'aller fruits et
légumes
frais et de saison c'est là où il y en a
le plus et ma grand mère elle était
horrifiée mais motivant je t'ai vu
naître je vais te voir pourrir
s'imaginait que en riant en diminuant
mon rayon de l'approvisionnement jeu
diminuer la quantité de nourriture halal
assiette
donc en fait j'étais invité par
énormément de structures des parents
d'élèves des partis politiques des
collectivités locales des écoles des
lycées et pour justement alertés mais en
fait on me demandait toujours le pour le
comment le comment
comment je me débrouille est-ce que ça
me coûte plus cher est ce que j'ai
toujours des amis parce que du coup je
devenais peu un peu lourd ou casse
couilles je viens à force de demander
toujours du local mais donc jamais vu
autant de monde mais en fait le pourquoi
de ma démarche c'est à dire le fait
qu'on risque de se taper dessus
si la perfusion alimentaire assurée par
le ballet des camions de la distribution
connaissait une avéré une avarice pour
ça que j'avais créé que j'avais intitulé
mon expérience de locavore hommage au
local d'accord mais c'était permettre un
territoire et à sa population de se
nourrir localement deux points une
question d'ordre public et en fait ça on
me l'a jamais demandé le pourquoi nomme
le courant oui en 2011
je suis élu conseiller général de l'aude
sur le canton de castelnaudary-nord ça
avait plus parce que j'avais fait avant
de promettre et j'avais montré qu'en
fait on pouvait faire rimer économie
écologie lien social et sécurité et je
me suis j'ai eu confirmation que chez
mes collègues conseillers généraux déjà
les circuits courts c'était déjà bien
d'en parler parce que jusque là il était
contre mais l'aspect sécurité alors là
c'était un autre monde et donc que ni la
les services pourtant les services
compétents
il pensait pas cette cette question de
vulnérabilité
donc du coup il ya deux ans je me suis
dit bon je vais reprendre mes études et
j'ai réalisé un master spécialisé en
gestion des risques sur les territoires
à cergy et pendant trois quatre mois je
me suis amusé afin d'amuser à la machine
à café
et a demandé aux intervenants c'est à
dire arriver des préfets des militaires
des professionnels des risques des
géographes ou autre voilà la chose
suivante est ce que le fait de ne pas
produire à côté de là où on consomme à
l'heure des cyberattaques par exemple
des menaces de blocage des flux
d'approvisionnement avec des populations
non préparée avec une société devenue
intolérante à la frustration
est-ce que ça c'est vu comme un risque
dans les endroits où normalement cette
question se pose est ce traité est ce
que le fait qu'on ait commencé par
courir après la nourriture lorsqu'on
était chasseur cueilleur après on s'est
posés on a inventé on l'a fait poussé
autour de nous ça a été au néolithique
on a inventé la de l'agriculture ensuite
pour sécuriser grandement les greg on
s'est organisés en communautés c'est là
où on inventé les villages et c'est là
où l'espace est devenue territoire
c'est aussi là qu'on a grandement et
menthe et la politique donc après qu'on
ait couru après la nourriture après que
les fait pousser au tour après que se
soient regroupées maintenant c'est la
nourriture et qui viennent à nous sans
qu'on se demande le comment et le
jusqu'à quand et si l'on regarde ce sur
quoi et est basée la légitimité
politique des ancêtres des mères les
consuls au moyen-âge
elles étaient exercées sur la base de
quatre sécurité la première c'était
lutter contre les envahisseurs de vous
fallait érigé et entretenir les remparts
la deuxième c'était la sécurité
sanitaire c'est lutter contre la mettre
en place un assainissement collectivités
contre des épidémies tout ça la
troisième c'est l ordre public sécurité
intérieure et la quatrième c'était la
sécurité alimentaire fallait que quoi
qu'il arrive il y assez de nourriture
dans l'enceinte de la ville
c'est pour ça qu avait été créée la
police des grains et la police italienne
et l'aménagement du territoire autour
étaient directement fléchés et une
historienne que j'ai fait intervenir un
historienne du moyen âge
monsieur larguier je lui avais demandé
lors de mon bilan de mon année de
locavore de zoomer sur les révoltes
freeman terre et ils avaient retrouvé
dans les archives de la ville de
narbonne
un arrêté municipal de 1720 à peu près
qui stipulait que sur certaines
parcelles
il était interdit de planter de la vigne
pourquoi parce qu'il fallait que ça
reste toujours en greg et pourquoi parce
qu'ils avaient le souvenir collectif
d'une dizaine qui s'était déroulé
quelques années avant alors c'était une
organisation une conscience des risques
et une responsabilisation collective
donc politique qui sera ajouté à une
conscience et une responsabilisation
individuelle c'est à dire que chacun
avait un petit bout de jardin
donc en fait c'est additionne la
individuelles et collectives n'empêchait
pas forcément les famines
mais on s à sauver les meubles après
arrive à napoléon y voit là où la moelle
et mère je me méfie c'est moi qui les
nomme donc c'est à partir de là que le
lien entre habitat édiles locaux s'est
distendu
et ça correspondait aussi à l'arrivée de
l'exploitation de la découverte de
l'exploitation des énergies facile les
énergies fossiles charbon et pétrole
pour lesquels sapiens n'ai pas fait
puisque ça c'est fort mais bien avant
que sa pièce n'arrive et du coup on
s'est affranchi des limites espace-temps
qui au fait que nos territoires qui
jusque là était le support de notre
subsistance va partir de ce moment là on
a fait venir la nourriture de loin et
c'est là que nos territoires à ce souk
de plus en plus spécialisés et la
spatialisation de nos territoires a été
grandement repas et c'est pour absorber
le flux démographiques puisque on a pris
énormément de population depuis cette
époque là arrive à mi terrain 80 n ai
dit voilà vous les maires je redonne des
pouvoirs mais c'est pas pour autant que
les maires à partir de 81 qui sommes
quand même le reflet de la société et
jeux
je suis élu je sais ce n'est pas pour
autant qu'ils ont repris à bras le corps
la question sur laquelle leurs ancêtres
étaient légitimes et non le foncier
nourissier est restée la variable
d'ajustement de toutes les autres
politiques c'est pour ça qu'il n'y a pas
dans les documents de planification
territoriale que sur le scot l'épée et
lui il n'ya pas l'alimentation qui est
prise en compte pourtant aussi
quantifier le nombre de crèches aussi
quantifier le nombre de deux zones
commerciales de théâtre de piscine ou
autre mais à la nourriture non on n'y
pense pas donc amenant tout cela on m'a
dit ah ouais ça ça a l'air d'être un
sujet js que dans le monde des risques
on pense la production est est-ce que
dans le monde de la production on
balance le monde des risques et il m'a
dit ah ouais ça c'est intéressant
donc du coup j'ai été encadrée par un
ancien colonel de l'armée et par un
géographe qui est directeur d'une
collectivité locale à un aménagement du
territoire s'intéresser également
ladiville à la dir est la division du
renseignement de la gendarmerie
nationale et également la zone de
défense et de sécurité de paris
donc en fait j'avais un encadrement pour
bien montrer que la démarche était
sérieuse et j'avais aussi donc des
cautions institutionnel qui faisait que
les jeunes que je suis allé interroger
et mais quelque part ils ont répondu
pour beaucoup c'est à dire que j'ai eu
plus de 50% de retour c'est énorme
en fait les résultats sont édifiants
réellement édifiant au point que oui
effectivement on ne pense pas
l'alimentation comme un risque dans nos
pays développés qui ont toujours eu le
ventre plein depuis longtemps on ne
passe l'alimentation que sur des excès
c'est à dire sur thomas malade mais
jamais sur un éventuel non accès il n'ya
pas d'aménagements alimentaire à du
territoire
il n'y a pas non plus dans les lois de
dans la loi gris culture alimentation ce
type de risques là il n'y a pas non plus
dans la loi de modernisation de la
sécurité civile de 2004
le risque de rupture d'approvisionnement
alimentaire n'ont plus d'eau petit lait
normal donc logique de cette logique-là
qu'il n'y ait pas dans les plans
communaux de sauvegarde ce type de
risques listés et qu'il est donc normal
quelque part logique qu'il n'y ait pas
d'aller dicrim les documents
d'information communal sur les risques
majeurs ce type de risque puisqu'il
n'est même pas passé ni à titre
individuel ni au niveau politique ni au
niveau de la technostructure donc j'ai
pointé tout ça et l'airé pose ce que
j'ai eus donc venant de généraux deux
colonels de spécialistes des risques
d'aller des hauts fonctionnaires
deux syndicats agricoles nationaux la
fédération nationale des safer des
diététicienne nutritionniste historiens
géographes a en fait oui c'est un angle
mort l'alimentation territorialisée et
la non préparation des populations n'est
pas vu comme un risque parce que je suis
passé par le continuum sécurité défense
c'est à dire ce qu'ils y entrent
le vigile de supermarché et le sous
marin lanceur de le sous marin nucléaire
lanceur d'engin c'est à dire qui s'il y
avait une rupture dans la peau de
l'approvisionnement le vigile seraient
débordés qui ferait appel à police
municipale qui seraient débordés qui
ferait appeler la police nationale qui
seraient débordés qui ferait appel à la
gendarmerie nationale qui seraient
débordés qui ferait appel au reste de
l'armée qui seraient affaiblies donc la
conclusion au vu de tous ces témoignages
c'est que ne pas produire à côté de là
où on consomme sans qu'il y ait de plans
et sandra voir des populations préparer
c'est un risque pour la sécurité
nationale ce qui a inspiré une sénatrice
de la haute-garonne françoise laborde
qui a porté ce sujet au sénat
et le résultat est que oui effectivement
c'est un risque qui est maintenant
dorénavant identifié puisque le
gouvernement arrêtera reconnu qu'il y a
ce risque là justement à l'heure de la
raréfaction du foncier à l'heure du jeu
règlement climatique à l'heure de la de
l'hyper sophistication des moyens de
l'approvisionnement donc en fait cette
petite question d'enfants on peut la
retrouver maintenant au niveau national
et j'en ai profité pour monter des
formations donc entre entre parenthèses
un diplôme universitaire sur les risques
d'effondrement les adaptations et pour
passer par l'économie sociale et
familiale parce que il est toujours bon
pour ouvrir les yeux d'ouvrir les
bouches et en tant que consommateur on
peut à travers sa consommation fléché
peut-être sans forcément changer le
monde mais déjà changé ce territoire
voilà je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]